this week on brian ross investigates
the us pulled out of afghanistan amid
chaos and confusion and corruption
but now hundreds of millions of dollars
in american taxpayers money is still
being sent there
is that money going to end up in the
hands of the taliban a terrorist group
well that's the big concern a warning
from the inspector general overseeing
money sent to afghanistan 380 million
dollars and counting
let me be blunt about this
we have seen this movie before
and unless we're very careful the money
will be converted and potentially lost
and go to terrorists plus no single
group has been hit harder by the opiate
prices than native americans on
reservations across the country i have
two children
that became addicted to heroin
there was a time i thought he's either
going to go to prison or he's going to
die
how one tribe in washington state is
using settlement money from drug
companies to fight the scourge it's
challenging for us because we consider
ourselves strong people and we consider
ourselves independent people we have
lots of struggling families and so we're
susceptible to
the folks getting caught up in the
opiates
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
and he came out and said he showed that
they won arizona that's an outright lie
from the studios of the law and crime
trial endeavor in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin tonight with an american scourge
not coveted 19 but the crisis with
opiates that has claimed tens of
thousands of lives and disrupted the
lives of so many more and no group in
our country has been harder hit than
native americans economically
disadvantaged with substandard medical
care and so susceptible to the addictive
power of the opiates legal and illegal
rhonda
that's right brian and now hundreds of
native american tribes have reached a
huge financial settlement with drug
makers and distributors who've been
blamed for their role in the crisis some
590 million dollars will be distributed
to tribes large and small
one of the tribes hit hard by the opiate
crisis is located just outside seattle
the jamestown slalom tribe
it's one of the smallest tribes involved
in the settlement but tribal leaders say
the money will mean a lot
and we're joined now by w ron allen who
is the chairman of the jamestown's
kalalam tribe mr allen thank you so much
for being here what's been the impact of
these uh prescription drugs uh the
addictions on your tribe
most of us are living you know um at
moderate to low income levels you know
we have lots of struggling families and
so we're susceptible to uh
the folks getting caught up in the
opiates so it causes a lot of disruption
um to our families um they become
dysfunctional they become dependent uh
we have some challenges some some will
end up in other kinds of crime and and
it's also spiritually for us and
culturally if i shouldn't say it that
way
it's a it's it's challenging for us
because we consider ourselves strong
people and we consider ourselves
independent people and then when you
see some of your people um start
becoming dependent on opiates and other
substance abuses
then it becomes very
disruptive to
the harmony of our community the tribe
says it will use the money it gets for a
new clinic on the reservation land and
chairman allen gave us a tour this is
our jamestown healing clinic
that we have built our building with
with respect to treating opiate and
substance abuse patients in our
community well behind me is
he's branching he's the director of our
healthcare
clinic uh clinics and molly martin is
the director of this we we call this the
healing center the belief is is that you
can't heal a person of their addiction
unless you heal the whole person that
includes their physical health their
mental health
and everything and so so we're going to
have quite extensive wrap around
services what's the biggest thing you
have to overcome with uh particularly
young members of the tribe who are
hooked on these opiates
well you know the biggest thing we have
it really if you want to know the truth
is the stigma
uh people want to come for help but
they're afraid to because of what people
say about it
everybody thinks that uh people are weak
that have addiction they think that
they haven't found the bottom of the
barrel yet and um and it's amazing
uh the lack of understanding around
mental health and addiction in this
country
i'd also add in that
a lot of people have misconceptions
about the medications that we're using
um and there's this idea that we're just
replacing one drug with another when in
reality we're giving a medication that's
been shown to help people heal and shown
to help
improve their health and their lives
without you know getting them high or
causing other side effects the way that
illicit opiates would and that's a big
barrier for people before they ever walk
through the walk through our doors is to
understand that these medicines are here
to help them not to create more problems
and how widespread do you see the issue
well this was one of the worst counties
in the country at one time
county hat which is where we're at
currently had the largest number of
opiate prescriptions
across washington state between 2006 and
2012.
so we are very familiar with how
significant this issue is in our
community and as illicit opiates like
heroin and fentanyl become more and more
readily available
we're seeing more and more people
struggling with those
and
we're we're here to help
one of the tribe citizens working at the
new clinic is shauna priest
whose two children fought addiction for
years my son started with
back pain so it was prescribed oxycodone
when he was cut off from that he
switched over to heroin
to be honest i'm not sure how my
daughter got started in it but they were
both
heroin addicts starting about the same
time
and i think it went on for about seven
years
what was that like for you as a mom
uh it was uh
something i have a hard time talking
about sometimes it was also terrifying
uh several times a day you know going in
there just making sure my son's chest is
still moving up and down making sure
he's still alive
finding you know needles in every nook
and cranny in the house
it was something that
it was very very
traumatizing and very um
something i wouldn't wish on anybody to
ever have to go through
you were afraid you were going to lose
him
definitely um
i had
high hopes that i really there was a
time i thought he's either going to go
to prison or he's going to die
one of the two
and was there any help you could find to
help get him off this addiction
we tried several rehabs
believe it or not the day he would come
home
he'd go right back to it just nothing
was helping
and then he started the
monthly injections
at the at our health clinic
and
that seemed to work really well for him
and in fact it's been
four years now
that he's been
clean from heroin
watching my kids go through it
and so from a mom's perspective
i know that there's hope and i know that
um
i just want to see
us be able to help as many people as we
can
that need it
in fact one of the my proudest moments
is that my son is working construction
with the tribe and he actually has
helped build our new healing clinic
so that to me is something really
outstanding
and my daughter is a assistant to a
manager at the casino for about three
years now they're thriving and just
doing fabulous and i owe everything to
um our program
your tribal name means strong people so
it must be very difficult for you to see
the impact
yes it is uh it's disappointing i mean
we
uh you know for centuries you know we
have been all tribes good in my tribe
have been dependent on the federal
government and one of our primary goals
is to be independent of the federal
government and be
dependent only on our own resources
we're
in the last
20 years or so
we've had great strides in achieving
that objective so um uh it is a big deal
to us uh and it has a lot to do with our
culture our identity our spirit and
we're very proud of how much we've
achieved but unfortunately opiates is a
newer uh challenge uh along with the old
uh the the historical uh substance
abuses like heroin and cocaine and and
math now
um so it's it's um it's been
disappointing but but we're we're
resilient you know we we get
disappointed but we don't get
discouraged uh we're gonna defeat it
all right w ron allen thank you so much
for being with us here tonight it's been
an honor thank you
coming up next you may have thought the
u.s was done with afghanistan but it
turns out we're still sending hundreds
of millions of dollars there in
humanitarian aid is that going to end up
in the hands of the taliban a warning
tonight from the inspector general in
charge
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
prime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate lawn crime in the
channel guide and for only 1.99 a month
you can add the network to your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to a warning about american
taxpayer money possibly getting into the
hands of terrorists as chaotic and
deadly as the us withdrawal from
afghanistan was last year it seemed the
country had put afghanistan and the
trillion dollars we spent there behind
us
but tonight the inspector general who
oversees money sent to afghanistan says
not so fast rhonda
that's right brian the people of
afghanistan are suffering terribly under
their new rulers the taliban starvation
the collapse of medical services women's
rights trampled and an economy in free
fall
the u.s has offered humanitarian aid but
this is a country with a legacy of
corruption and a government tied to
terrorists brian
we're joined now by john sopko the
special inspector general for
afghanistan reconstruction who for the
last decade has been watching what the
u.s has spent tens of billions of
dollars and what's happened to that
money mr sapko we're out of afghanistan
now but we're still sending hundreds of
millions of dollars to afghanistan
uh you're absolutely correct and it's a
pleasure to be here brian uh
we
meaning u.s government because of the
humanitarian crisis or
have sent over 380 million dollars
uh and so has the un is saying they need
up to eight billion dollars because of
the humanitarian crisis
is that money going to end up in the
hands of the taliban a terrorist group
well that's the big concern as you said
in your recent speech we've seen this
movie before
yeah yes we have and uh
the concern is that
we're going to spend too much money
and too fast and too small a country
with too little oversight and unless
we're very careful the money will be
diverted and potentially lost and go to
terrorists
as you look back on your decades running
uh the special inspector general's
office for afghanistan how much money do
you think was wasted that went there of
the tens of billions
well
you know that's a tough question we
we've been asked by congress uh on a
number of occasions to document
total amount lost
we we gave a very conservative estimate
of about 30
uh it could be higher but about you know
three three dollars out of every 10 was
lost to waste fraud or abuse
so how do you prevent that from
happening now with the money we're
sending supposedly to help the
humanitarian crisis well the first thing
is learn from the prior mistakes
make certain you
have an acceptable you agree beforehand
on an acceptable amount of risk you're
willing to take and if the risk exceeds
that stop spending it the
monitor the money see how the money is
being spent i mean these sound like
really simple
proposals but they weren't carried out
in the past
what was your reaction as you watched
the rapid chaotic withdrawal of u.s
forces and personnel from afghanistan
well i think i like anybody who watched
it were
saddened uh by it and concerned
myself
we had staff in afghanistan at that time
uh
u.s employees because we had the largest
law enforcement u.s law enforcement and
u.s audit presence in afghanistan at
that time so we were concerned about
getting those people out
which we fortunately did
as an inspector general you're
independent non-political what do you
say about the performance of the biden
administration in terms of afghanistan
well
i i'll just say there there are plenty
of
mistakes that were made by all
administrations and you read our reports
going back 10 years
this is not
a partisan issue this is an issue of a
good government and uh
and
i i think uh
i you know i'm not going to say one
administration was worse than the other
we've had multiple administrations of
multiple parties and they're all
problems that we've identified
finally let me ask you this given what's
happened in afghanistan
did we accomplish anything
yeah we did accomplish quite a bit uh
unfortunately with the lost uh to the
taliban a lot of those gains
uh
are in peril and uh i think the most
obvious one that uh your your viewers
would recognize is that
you know we tried to bring some
semblance of uh uh
of
human rights protection for women and
girls uh
and
that is
is in peril
and
because the taliban although they have
said they respect women's rights
we really haven't seen much of that so
uh
i think the gains we have made in health
care in education uh
those are all been uh
i wouldn't say totally destroyed but uh
they're likely to totally be lost
john sopko the special inspector general
for afghanistan reconstruction thank you
so much for being with us here tonight
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
was chosen as your winner of this week
brian kilmeade of fox who broke ranks
and actually called president trump a
liar let's look at this
right now nobody cares about 2020 nobody
and everything that he said and the
challenges that he made should have been
done before the election and they did a
recount in arizona and the recount
showed no difference almost and he came
out and said it showed that they won
arizona that's an outright lie
and please stop wasting our time with
that because he's capable of doing so
much more
well what do you make of that aidan
well so this is part of an ongoing
effort on behalf of a lot of trump's
media supporters to convince the former
president to stop spreading lies about
the 2020 election and move on to
subjects that americans actually care
about uh brian kilmeade who is the host
of fox and friends trump's favorite
morning show said there on his radio
show that the 2020 election is not a
priority for many americans despite the
fact that trump keeps bringing it up in
his rallies and in his statements to
supporters um that's all fair but that
comment that you played right there that
kill me made which is calling specific
claims that trump has made about the
2020 election calling them outright lies
that's really notable and that stands
out against previous comments that other
trump supporters have made um i should
note that it also contrasts a lot with
what other hosts at fox news have said
about this um i spoke to uh pete
heggseth
a top fox news host recently and i asked
him if he could tell me who won the 2020
election and he could not answer that
question so there are still many hosts
out there that are struggling with that
question on fox news and in right-wing
media um we wanted to give brian
kilmeade kudos for being clear-eyed
about it and saying we know that the
2020 election was won by joe biden
donald trump challenged this in the
courts the courts including ones uh
which were run by uh trump trump
appointed judges threw all these
challenges out we know who won the 2020
election let's move on
in this case though brian kilmeade said
this on radio not on his tv show
right and i do think that that's notable
um brian kilmeade's radio show obviously
has a much smaller audience uh than fox
and friends which is the show that he
hosts for three hours every day
now he has in the past in the past
couple of years when trump was president
after trump left office occasionally
challenged the president um so i will
give him props for that but it is
notable that he's saying this on his
radio show and not on fox and friends
let's move on now to the loser this week
james bennett formerly of the new york
times who ran the new york times opinion
page why is he a loser
so james bennett who until recently was
the top editor of the opinion pages of
the new york times took stand in a trial
uh over an opinion piece the paper
published a few years ago um he left the
uh paper uh recently you'll remember
over a backlash over an opinion piece
that was published by tom cotton calling
for the military to be brought in to
handle protesters uh over the killing of
george floyd um this trial is about a
different opinion piece um that the new
york times published it was published by
the editorial board and it claimed that
the shooting of then congresswoman gabby
giffords was incited by an ad
run by sarah palin's super pac um james
bennett who was part of the editorial
board at the time inserted that line
establishing that link at the last
minute now there was no link between
those two events and the times had to
correct the story the next day uh now
sarah palin is suing the paper for
defamation um and james bennett uh said
in testimony that he takes full
responsibility for that line being added
um he said that the pressing deadline of
the paper going to print was what made
him hastily add that line that ended up
being incorrect um but it resulted in
this major lawsuit and a huge headache
for the new york times
obviously mistakes happen for major
publications like the new york times but
this was a serious one that has resulted
in a lawsuit now
that threatens to challenge the first
amendment protections that the paper has
in this case though he did not blame
some lower level researcher or deputy
and took full responsibility and issued
a correction the next day
i think that's admirable that he took
full responsibility but it's still a
serious error to establish this link of
inciting violence between uh sarah
palin's super pac
and the horrible tragedy that happened
um the you know the good news for the
new york times is that uh the press
enjoys pretty pretty good protections um
against defamation lawsuits uh sarah
palin and her lawyers will have to prove
that they acted with actual malice and
knew what they were printing was
incorrect
and did so regardless which is a really
hard thing to prove and is part of the
reason why the new york times has not
lost one of these defamation lawsuits in
decades
so this is a lawsuit being closely
followed by everybody in the media and
libel lawyers to see how it comes out
sarah palin versus the new york times
it'll be a big verdict when it comes aid
mclaughlin thank you so much for being
with us here tonight
thanks brian and thanks to all of you
for joining us this evening and thanks
to our great staff here at long crime
for guinea is on the air and off the air
every single week
[Music]
so
you